this client still chunky and then you
send another vector over and outside but
if you pay attention you're taking their
center of gravity and you're creating a
spiral like this
and the spiral is so it goes down and it
starts to build up so terrific low
energy but it doesn't stay here on this
two-dimensional plane
the spiral itself this trout is
traveling and turning so his Center is
going to go something like there's a
check he gets moved to the outside right
this pie was not turning and out he goes
so for the example iki oh there's the
check it gets brought to the outside and
the spiral is now turning and out he
goes you have that confucius that's the
transition back can you use it all the
time so he's here he comes in I'm gonna
use it all the time
okay he throws his punches right I'm
using it all the time okay that's the
front inward happen okay
I'm doing how to punch inward a battery
murder the front outlet and a back
outward
I just do that over and over there's a
spiral movement through space on the
sagittal plane I have rotated and you
just do it over and over that is the
most efficient way to get his head to
trade places with his feet so his head
hits the earth okay and we've been
focusing a lot on the front Edward so
you killed doesn't it but all the time
when he comes into attack like yesterday
you're using it every single time every
single time
okay now let's lay with the back outward
okay
so again from here I'm gonna have to do
this same exact thing over here I'm
going to get a center then go down to
come out and he starts turning the other
way now
so his body his center does not go in
and then back and I'm not sitting here
and show me him his head
creating some sort of angle of
disturbance with his head
facing support I'm not doing that boom
later get the ten down start to bring
the whole spa goes to the outside and
now we rotate it not this way
but this way whoa this is our position
[Music]
with you don't you're not an attacker as
you can okay
you are lorry equal to a barbell if you
can fight barbell bends in the middle
breaks decides to roll off the bench I'm
returning it to Amazon you got it so
when you go like this like that if you
lose your grip
you're in terrible horrible I can't
condition myself with you so Lucas job
is to have final displacement and to
stay connected with their fulcrum not by
the strength of their fingers but by
moving their 7 to keep that connection
with the palms oh my goodness OH
you see boy I'd rip his open my
like a suction cup is on there so he
starts to move quietly my feet here I
might depend on the finger strength but
nobody seemed to be that strong instead
you're training on your own energy
reconciliations on how to do that with
tai sabaki so that's my measuring that's
my metric right there he starts to move
easy I still in that perfect pump on
without my fingers what I have to do my
body has to do John I use that I can't
hold it anymore but he gets to now
beautiful outward back out where Kazushi
path get it I don't like this we're not
winning okay so try harder as you get go
okay so we're watching this as it hasn't
sent remove live where he was go did it
move no if you see that okay so what you
guys said to watch is the technique in
your head and watch this technique which
is at position 5 because the position
pattern is your master key move in terms
of tactical application right right now
if you just watch the arm when you go
like this with your arm I can't use that
anyway instead you watch this Center Co
centers moving there goes it down you
see now I don't want to say that this
whole spiral has to come to his outside
in this space woman you see all the way
and then which way this way this way as
it's turning out
[Music]
so you get here nope you should have
just a bending back and your
compensation your Aikido closer or you
start looks pretty good looks pretty
good
looks pretty good then you start going
by you see going on a straight line and
you give him back the balance it's all
pretty good it's pretty good then you
give him back his own deposit should be
spitting him so let's take the footwork
out and Michael drill it
it's get you here however you want in
the back corner and you're just thinking
about making his center to that copper
it's going to go down out move forward
now ba this way
[Applause]
my feet are together no shooter together
you know I'm his center
don't worry go here there gets pinned on
that leg you see once I get hidden on
that leg I let it keep going
don't don't pin this leg on me okay this
way this way that leg will kick up you
get it the dissenters doing that now I
got the tilt you see and I need this
here to go on the next pattern so the
head goes this way you see and the hip
will go out this way
don't you'll spark their ear thread
cyclone they'll start pulling out so I
don't use the footwork here
just get him turning right turning
turning this way and now I'm not going
to kill it we're next time he's not
going to want to play okay but I did the
pattern and now I need to that way at
first then this way this is hot this way
okay here you go and then you start
pushing them they go forward
see that little thing that were you held
your breath that's where you felt the
morning okay that's why I need you to
hit is that boy warm you're not going to
hit it you're gonna feel very rest
assured why keep you going
oh I'm painted to the power your Center
is go
it's true you might be using it
different ways but it's still a training
venue and there's more things that
you're going to get out of it if you
stick to the pattern then if you turn it
into a tackle application so for example
we've been working on ego from swazaa
well that front anymore position pattern
that handles this way the handle system
so you don't need to do the technique
and you definitely don't need it if he's
dissing dressing we don't need it you
see you could leave that all out on the
out on the back upward spiral behind
does not go this way the hand goes this
way this way the front did work this way
the back outward this way
you get it see a lot of you go like this
we just try and knock on that
don't try to knock them down what goes
this way I mean here it's not a
free-for-all boom no here
is that removing all the top
so he's gonna try to get his foot back
down he's gonna get his foot down if I
don't new pattern okay sit down okay if
I do tired he was actually gonna forward
he's going forward he's not going out he
takes the shape that you guys see but
his his inertia and momentum is not boy
but you're good spiral is being used a
flower progressing spiral is being used
to turn his body in what you think is
backwards direction when you reverse the
direction of
laughter you don't do it you give them a
box and sometimes even if you go up high
you go black he's still into it you guys
okay
play with that then you feel that you
weren't honest with is that you have to
use your this must share you can tell
you what push it on you want it to not
pay attention to it so here's where you
go and then you're like I'm going to do
that look now you're pushing on him
you're just the musician if you pay
attention actually happens before my
hand goes by hey oh yeah it's not here
and then he's still a balance no this
power is here then the throw has the X
pattern
okay try it again
and I'm just going to go out so I'm
going to be connected to him you feel
that right there now his interview pass
to me and now he's with me okay if I
stay on here and I just turn he just
turned her that I didn't he came from
and went back to so the first thing is
oh okay
we're just going out that's all we're
doing okay it's very small don't sit
here and try to get it's a very small
movement which is okay try okay so when
you're living again you're not pulsing
and you're not an attacker you are a
barbell okay and I don't want a barbell
that jumps up and down do you get it so
you have a constant pressure and we're
going to work the right front handlers
that's all we're doing so I don't want
to see anyone go out this everyone is
going out this okay so he's there right
and you're gonna feel your energy pass
through right there did you see and did
you feel like your smile okay so I'm
here and then that's it what do I mean
by the right side this here release
okay only the right side that means
you're going we're just working the
first part out do that same thing okay
so set it out I see that so here here
his body the body moves but here you're
going to need to get that so you see the
tilt in your shoulders you see that
plane right there it's here in the out
link this way I might have the down what
do I originally want it is full spot
spine to tilt you see that in a fight
that little tilt was actually all out of
me and always try to get in training you
elongated and belong it for training
purposes okay so here I am I'm only
doing the right side absorb then it's
not this and you're just going to get
that I have to move his body so if you
pay attention
his body's going this way boom and I'm
getting moving out of there not just up
top okay try
now he's got the same thing but we don't
have that okay don't start losing the
connection here never see the same thing
can you drive this is not magic so of
course you can replicate the same
pattern externally so you can go however
you do not have the energy is energy
stop my energy when I need them
I'm use my energy to do something to him
okay so you can't go you can't go like
that
yeah but his energy never comes in and
where that starts to fall apart is Wang
Zi stronger than me right and I can't
push that back or when I'm not doing an
obvious angle of this one being straight
and I go like that so for example here I
am at this one which I might be right
maybe he's trying to stab me or
something you see and so he has his
energy and you're gonna feel it this is
external and then you're gonna feel it
in there okay and then I can do the same
thing the same thing where if I do this
like this this is going to
yeah so try not to do that use your mind
to feel easy Oh stick your hand out
there if you want right and feel the
lock the way the body is walking pretty
killer okay let's try it again
so it's a you don't rope so for me to go
to the left
get up what I have to do before I can
put down to the right and I'm sorry okay
so it's like light between you got a
turn right to go left
okay if that's how it goes then out all
the back and he has the same thing he's
on the back okay and we'll start with
two okay
and oh no no boom
he said I'm settled again I'm not
leaning back under seven air like
yesterday all right so I know I wanna go
like that I want to go up and out so
what do I have to do first in and down
in down there now
okay try and we're only doing the right
side again
more in so do you see how you guys have
a problem going in that's the part where
you guys start going back too soon and
that's where you give them back their
foot and so I'll show you what it looks
like so you you going here just going
back okay and probably what it is is
when you're like this you like oh you
see you trying to go that's hair for you
here
No
hey you going here and I'm going to say
this the reason why you don't want to go
here is because you want to push back
line and you feel like when you start to
push you feel their push so you're like
that was really heavy so the next rep
you look less of their push together and
then you're gonna try to go here and
again you're just moving your shoulders
if you see like I'm the first one on the
front so it's
bring in your hand they try to help you
let that energy into your mind otherwise
their energy is not your image so you
often here I'm gonna use their energy
against them you get it that's not what
we do their energy is my image okay so
their energy comes into me and now now I
as I move with their energy that's
different
I'm moving with their energy I use their
energy against them they're not the same
thing I'm used to fight their energy
against them is still an antagonism is
still a dichotomy okay so I have to let
their energy into me I got a little pass
through me hold it now we're not gonna
move you see that using their energy
against them please is with deviation so
he goes then I won that's not what I'm
doing
I'm letting his energy em push his
energies in me and now I'm just moving
with this is he not
okay so you've got to let it we try it
and the projections the young face of
every throw is entirely dependent upon
the quality of the in face
I cannot project you very far if I do
not let you get very far so when you go
like that it's very little to get taste
it's actually very little dog faces okay
so try again we review this last video I
want you to see how you very come
forward barely coming okay don't like
this this is a different shoulder set
okay
shoulder set it's still my turn don't
bring this in here
keep it out out up don't absorb it when
you come stop you couldn't see
you have your I'll be here you absorb me
that's that brother any safety you can
scare you
did he not fall did he not call me Kimmy
yes he did yes he did turn around you
keep your Center lock the entire time so
he feels you the entire time
if you lose your balance you're going to
fall you're leaning too far it's smaller
it's smaller I've been in this drill is
smaller you leaning too far leg is
energy in first first
but and you reach for the mattress did
you see that that's what I mean by
cracky bar
so don't you don't take that
and nutrition your centers don't do the
obvious yeah don't go up say you don't
wanna go up what's my center actually do
seven goes down Jenna do you guys
understand right
so you don't need your house to go up
doesn't mean your century goes down I
know if I want to go up
it's the same law for the state
organization and integrity is what you
use is not yet so when you're here and
you take it in your wrist or your elbows
or your shoulders you are disorganizing
to get it and you're not practicing so
you letting her energy go through you is
the same steel Bhagat is using when they
let you kids energy go through them you
get it so don't start taking it like she
brings us back if you bend your elbow
connector Center maintain the
organization go lock recenter don't come
up go down
okay we got a lot of work to do right